hey Colonel Brian here I hope everyone
watching this right now is being safe I
hope you're washing your hands and I
hope like me you're hunkered down at
home I thought maybe I could be of some
help by offering a life hack a lot of
people out there are worried right now
about toilet paper people are going to
stores and they seem to want more toilet
paper
than they could ever use in a six-year
period if they had continual diarrhea
and now it's gone it's all gone and
people are panicking I'm here to assure
you there are many things around the
house you can use instead of toilet
paper that work just as well for example
CBS receipts CBS receipts are long this
is for just six tic tacs I bought I
never throw em away because I knew this
day would come
also we all have these around the house
Valpak they'll Pat coupons I know you
never really use them now look at that
you can clean yourself with colorful
coupons you probably have some stocks
around the house and aren't really worth
as much as they used to be these are
mostly stocks I bought for Carnival
Cruise Line that last was too hard and
too long I apologize you can use
souvenir t-shirts t-shirts someone gave
you you don't value you hate them you
can't get rid of them I have thousands
of these so I've been wiping my ass with
these 24/7 another thing souvenir
baseball caps like this one you're
thinking baseball cap how does that work
Conan you take your fist you put it in
the ball of the hat right there you Jam
that up in the area and you work it
around just work that around works
better than toilet paper really clean it
clean well one thing I would not
recommend marshmallow peeps trust me
it's not pleasant and you end up kind of
feeling bad for the little chick finally
we all have them pretentious coffee
table books I've had this on my coffee
table for nine years I don't know who
Joe Cooney
who's that that's not art wipe your ass
with it that's my life hack I hope it's
of use to you stay well take care we'll
talk to you soon